[Music]
governor andrew cuomo announced recently
that new york will begin a major
reopening on may 19th
wow an open city what's that going to be
like
you know what it's been so long that i
can't quite remember
me either the streets have been so empty
for the past year
but now the city is going to be full of
people again i guess
yeah we will have to have a normal daily
routine
that involves leaving the house with
other
people wait a second guys
i think i'm starting to remember
you wake up you go to that place you've
been
a thousand times before
and there's a picture of a little coffee
cup
right on their front door what's that
place called again
starbucks that's right i'm starting to
remember
you walk to work it's quite a slap
but there's this stuff you don't want on
your shoes so you
watch every step it's all dog [ __ ]
that's right it's everywhere we
can't wait to do it all
even the parts we can't recall cause
this city is
a stranger stares and holds his gaze
as i walk by him he shouts a special
phrase it's a i love the way that ass
shake oh yeah they yelled that a lot you
get to
work in socialize
[Music]
that weird office girl talks about this
as she looks you
right in the eyes oh the progression of
her foot fungus from treatable to
untreatable we find it
quite appealing
[Music]
[Applause]
i cannot wait to see my friends
to talk to the guy whose stories
never end
i'll visit my bodega and their cat
and i'll smile when the cashier says wow
you've gotten so
fat we've all gotten so bad
get out from behind your computer
enjoy the fear of an active
we're gonna need a bigger bra the city
[Music]
oops
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you